réaction très sobre de la présidente de
la région ile de france valérie pécresse
avant d'entrer en politique en 2002 elle
avait été conseillère de jacques chirac
l elysée et pour la petite anecdote
c'est elle qui avait appris à l'époque
au président à manier les nouvelles
technologies est lui aussi a côtoyé de
près l'ancien président le préfet des
yvelines jean jacques brot a été l'un de
ses collaborateurs au début des années
2000 il parle d'un homme d'état
pragmatique
la députée yvelinoise or berger remercie
l'ancien chef d'état pour son engagement
sur l'écologie ainsi que son discours
sur la rafle du vel d'hiv
pour la première fois en 1995 un
président reconnaissait la
responsabilité de la france dans les
déportations de juifs
pour le maire de poissy karl olive la
france pleure le grand jacques et lui
dit merci président de son côté le
sénateur hibino à michel laugier évoque
un homme humain et chaleureux homme
qu'il avait eu l'occasion plusieurs fois
d'interviewer dans les années 80
lorsqu'il était journaliste
enfin le maire de rambouillet marc
robert souligner sa politique humaniste
tourner vers les territoires
l'ancien président s'était rendu à
plusieurs reprises à rambouillet et
avait notamment accueilli nelson mandela